you were working ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so I
just wanted to talk to you guys today
and let you know and update you and kind
of fill you in on what's been going on
with me in the past couple of months a
lot of you guys have probably noticed
that the upload schedule and the channel
hasn't been as regular as it usually is
and there is a reason for that and the
reason is I've actually been writing a
book it's called new thinking and it's
essentially the whole story of Science
and Technology from the Industrial
Revolution until 2020 so the research
involved in that has been quite heavy
and a bit more than I first anticipated
so it's taken a lot of my time and hence
the reason there's not as many videos as
they usually are during this period I've
got a bit burnt out as well so little
break was needed just to recharge a
little bit as well but the good news is
I've just finished the first draft so I
have more time to actually work on
videos now which is good if you want to
get an idea of what's in the book I have
this graphic that I've made up which
I'll put on the screen obviously it's
not the final version of the graphic but
you get an idea of just what the content
is here and you can see here that it
covers quite a lot it goes through most
of the major events and most of the
major people and the great minds who
made our world what it is today it's
quite exciting and I did really enjoy
writing it and researching some of the
stuff in there for those of you
wondering the release date was initially
October but has been pushed back to
January of 2019 the book will be out on
Amazon there'll be an audiobook version
they're said to be a few other online
distributors there's going to be both
hard copies and digital copies available
and also there's going to be a Chinese
version both in print and also audiobook
for those interested in the future I
think I'll be doing some more videos on
some topics in the book they'll be under
the new thinking series of which I've
only done two videos in this channel so
far but anyway the main point was just
to highlight that there will be more
videos coming up from here on out anyway
thanks for watching and being patient
and I guess I'll see you again soon for
the next video so until next time this
has been - go go you've been watching
ColdFusion cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion its me thinking